hi my name is Anthony's up Nick I work
for Wolfram research talking today about
Wolfram cloud connector for Excel this
is a new product that we we've been
working on for the last year and we're
gonna be releasing soon thank you to
talk to you about the product I've been
working on the last year which is
Wolfram cloud connector for Excel I do
present at last year's I recognize some
of you from from last year
and we've we've got a long way since
then a lot of polish has been added and
some other features which i think you
might find some interesting I'll try to
differentiate you from last year's
presentation as well so that you
wouldn't get bored okay so so what is
the cloud connector for Excel the cloud
connector for Excel is a plugin for
Excel it can be quite difficult to make
these these plugins that do anything
particularly useful you either have to
ride them in C which can be quite
difficult or you write VBA code which is
awful because you're really limited to
the visual basic language and sandbox
within Excel it's not it's not a
pleasant experience in my first
iteration of this product I wrote a lot
of this stuff in VBA and it was
appalling it really limits you to to a
certain subset of features that a
product can do so this is written in in
in in c-sharp if you have any interest
in that
but basically you know the idea of this
plug-in is you know it's a product for
the Wolfram Enterprise private cloud and
you can call the enterprise Wolfram
private cloud from Excel and the reason
why this is beneficial is you know you
can access any Wolfram language function
from within Excel if you if you if you
wanted to and I'll talk to you details
about how how this is done as we go on
so let me just show you an example I'm
just just to show you the product itself
I don't know last time I last time I
presented I I think I went through 10
slides before I even showed the product
so so let's go straight into him fire up
Excel and hopefully it will work this is
um this is not my machine my machine
broke down yesterday so this is actually
wrong oh no this is the data like ever
so fine I don't even read my own own
bullet points so so basically what I
want to do is this is an example I've
done in like inform function and stuff
like that in the past and it's basically
creating a classifier from 40,000
recipes and this this this this data set
was taken from this nature paper which
have a look at you know food pairings
between between cultures and stuff like
that so the data set kind of looks like
it looks like this so you have a list of
ingredients and you have a cuisine so
this this first column is the cuisine
and as we go down you know you've got
North America and you've got south south
east asian western european etc etc so
you've got a nice data set here of a
bunch of ingredients for some recipe
doesn't say what the meal is that we're
not particularly interested in that
we're interested in where that meal came
from so so what we can do in the Wolfram
language is just wrap this thing around
with classifier and you clean the data a
little bit for convenience but but
basically you can just write classify
around it and it will do some work for
you so I want to show you the code for
the classic way I mean a super super
simple code anyway let's just zoom in
here actually maybe when zoom in because
the plot that comes back Quebec so let
me show you the product so the product
we have this nice little wolfram tab and
Wolfram have has a bunch of things which
I'll I'll talk to you about this is a
little bit less attractive in in Windows
7
but it looks okay I think so we have it
about page with this our logo preference
is this far thing which I'll talk to you
about this cloud API which has a
separate slide being able to
enable/disable api's and a recalculate
workbook button for convenience but
anyway I have this hopefully it's not
too small i zoom in a bit but I know
that the results gonna come back really
big so we have this function Wolfram API
and it's quite simple so I created an
API which has a URL of URI of WTC 2017
slash recipe classified plot and then I
can give some parameters some
ingredients which are in the cells b2 to
b4 so these ingredients bacon apple and
tomato I don't really have a cuisine in
mind here but if I just run this this
API what I should get back is a graphic
and this graphic gives me some
information so the ingredients were you
know you bacon apple tomato and it says
that this is very likely to have been
African cuisine
oh no Eastern European cuisine it goes
in order so it's over 40 percent likely
to be Eastern European and 20 percent
likely to be Western European so that's
kind of neat and I might change one of
these ingredients and say avocado if
suddenly I changed one of these
ingredients for avocados
we see that the probability goes that
it's you know it seems to think it's a
hundred percent almost a hundred percent
likely to have come from Latin America
so this is cool
you can do this you get these graphical
responses you see this you know live
value you know evaluated the code change
the change the information that was in
within this within this cell when
then call themselves they call them
shapes in Excel for any of these any
image or whatever but you don't need to
know that kind of information I'm a you
know want to get the raw information out
of the probability so I made a separate
recipe classifier which just gives the
the probabilities are the probabilities
come out in in some Association and the
Association looks like this so now I've
got the data and I've got you know for
this just chicken and bacon we can see
no point 1 so 10% for Western European
10% for Eastern European whatever and
then if I wanted to if I really want to
use Excel which I don't I you know I
want to use Excel as little as possible
I can make my my chart where where are
we here insert yeah I missed it I mean
it's different on my on my version of
Excel I usually use here so I can make
this chart I mean it's not as nice
looking as the previous one I don't know
if you agree but you know you've got
you've got a lot of different stylistic
option changes that you can make and
then this is obviously this will change
live as well so this is this is kind of
neat as well oh this one ever caught if
I have a card of it right yeah okay let
me let me let me add some more
ingredients so like beef pepper what
else I've already got chicken ah do let
me just try this I'll just change this
to be just c4 and run this again okay
that was a bit different but you at the
point that it's it's live updating so so
that's you know you can only also you're
kind of getting an idea of the speeds
here as well okay so that's the you know
basically the product you know I'll show
you some more features as we go on
and as I said before you know this is an
EPC product product essentially you know
what is what is an EPC what an EPC is
you know well we call it the Wolfram
Enterprise private cloud and that's you
know your own private cloud the cloud
that lives on your you know within your
infrastructure you can connect it up to
your data sources you have you have
freedom to run whatever you want on it
you can connect it to your devices you
don't have to run any kind of sandbox
mode like you do in in the public cloud
all these things are kind of useful the
main the main things are you know for
the for the cloud to me are you know
api's forms scheduled tasks and reports
these the main features that really are
designed for for for a cloud so to have
that kind of power within your private
cloud is really really useful so you
know this EP c runs on a VM which means
they can be very simple to install very
simple to create multiple copies of if
you need to have multiple private clouds
on site or on multiple sites and connect
them together yeah so so that's the
that's product you know if you want more
information about enterprise private
cloud I'm sure there were talks about it
but there is a very good website which
gives you a lot of information about
about the IEP C so you know you've got
the Y EPC and then this Y a PC and it
gives you a bunch of information use
cases they use you this use case is
actually pretty good very detailed
information on you know how you know how
you can create a our full system from
start to finish within within within the
Wolfram technology stack so yeah anyway
but feel free to check that website out
really quite useful so the May
thing about the product that that I've
created is you know they run on API
functions I may know I made that clear
before but basically the API function
function everything that you do you know
any function that you deploy there can
be essentially used with a very minor
amount of tweaking within within Excel
so you know API functions are written
entirely in the Wolfram language which
is really really beneficial so you don't
have to write something in one language
and then access it from another I mean
this stuff gets can get really tricky
and this is the great thing about about
our our technology stack is we have one
language to do everything which is which
is genuinely amazing I'm not sure that
any company does it as as well as we do
so yeah so you know the API functions I
mean it's kind of obvious but if it's
not you know they run in the you right
they run in town I guess they don't
always run in the cloud because you can
run you know locally you know create
local API functions and stuff like that
and act system within the Wolfram
language so so I guess that's even a lie
but but for this purpose you know they
they need to run in the cloud you know
you call these API is by a web request
so you have a web request from excel
that calls your cloud and gets the
information back and the main thing
reason you know why we're using API
functions is because they're very simple
to write you know and I'll show you how
simple it is and they're very quick to
deploy and I'll show you now you know
just to prove to you that it's simple so
I'm going to create an API so I'm just
gonna wrap cloud deploy first and then
I'm gonna go and I'm going to construct
this kind of in a nice way so that you
can see what's happening easier so I'm
gonna have some image which I'm going to
call a and some image which I'm going to
call B because I'm not very imaginative
and my my variable names and then what
I'm going to do
is I'm gonna do imagery style because
that's kind of a neat function so I'm
going to increment I when I get my
images I'm gonna go image a restyled
with image B so nothing too complicated
the to get this to work in the cloud
connector I just have to add this this
thing cloud allowed cloud extra
parameters fine and let me just call it
restyle and then I'm gonna get set
permissions to public so I run this and
it's called restyle and then what I'll
do is I will just open a new thing here
and I need to get some images so let's
go to Chrome and say I want to and Van
Gogh because I want to look like van
Gogh a van Gogh portrait so I'm gonna i
was massive I'm not gonna take that one
I'll take this one this one seems fine
I'll save this over it here fine I don't
need to name it anything and then I'll
go use this far thing so this far this
is really cool so the fact is I can I
can reference files within Excel so that
they they can be interacted with
directly so I got this great picture of
me my wedding I got married just just a
month ago
thanks and I'll take this image so I
call this a obj image B and then I'll
say equals Wolfram API and then I said
it was called restart right
and then I'll say parameter a is me
because I'm Reese and the restyling
parameter is B so hopefully actually
there is one thing that I wanted to
change because I know this takes this
can take some time so what I'm going to
do is I'm going to resize the images
once they come over to the to the
to the server so that so the only good
thing is a you know I've just I just
replaced that API so I can update these
things so let's see if this works
you know it's problem with live coding
is it may fail there we go we got to get
it to work a work of art like van Gogh
would have done himself I don't know
what happened to my face I mean
everything else looks ok when my face is
just gone wrong oh yeah it's cool so you
know this was all life you know that was
me writing the code deploying it getting
my data and then and then interacting
with it within Excel super super fast
super simple I could send this to you
you could use it okay so you know why
you know why have we created this
product well I kind of already gone over
this I'm running out of time as well
already
so we basically can do so much more than
Excel can do you know it's it's amazing
you know you know you guys pretty much
all Wolfram language developers you know
having that within Excel to have someone
who doesn't know how to use the Wolfram
language even though it's quite simple
people get scared of new things they are
now able to do it in an environment
which is comfortable to them so the good
thing is that it supports these you know
excel typical Excel workflows so you
know you can you know you people who
have already got their Excel
spreadsheets all set up they can just
slot in these new Wolfram api's very
simply and easily and and yeah
everything is done like all these
computations are done on the server so
you know these days is quite popular to
have these these kind of I can't
remember the tip of the term of the
shell machines are but they don't have
any power basically and they can only
really run as a small set things so if
you allow server to do like these called
cool computations there
you know then you can have cheaper
machines and just have better service
which it can be more convenient for the
company so let's let's hook up to some
real world data so I love this I I do
this is another example that I use but I
wanted to link it up to excel is this
cambridge website is cambridge website i
want them to change this because and one
day someone from cambridge will will see
my tour can be like maybe we should
change this because they have this email
address lookup and they have a little
API where you can basically look up any
any set of email addresses so i can say
you know look up the surname with people
with the surnames a bee and i've got a
list of all these people who have
surnames a bee from their departments
and and their email addresses so you
know what if i want to hook up to this
api right so i'll show you the code
afterwards but basically i hooked up to
this apt you know this kind of API that
they have and i made a you know a
cambridge api and i can just fill in the
surname and it will expand out for me
so there's my information you know now
there's all my information all my emails
rest is now i can mass email these
people we won't do that but this is
academic purposes in actually i had
someone who who are son wants a name any
names but who asked me for this for this
for this for this stuff and as i know
but but basically yeah it's really cool
and look at look at the responses you
know they're pretty they're pretty good
they're pretty fast and this isn't even
in ideal situations so so we've got
really fast response times to get all
these email addresses and and you know
it's more about connecting to your your
company's api is not you know not
stealing other people's data but it's
just to give you an idea of its public
so i assume is fine
so yeah anyway the api's i mean just in
case you are interested you know i do
this URL fetch of the website and then i
had some parameters and it gives me like
a response like this this is technical
but I know is you most of your
developers so I get this stuff back and
and basically all I have to do is you
know get certain certain data out so I
do do string cases to get to get the
chunk of email addresses and data and I
see that they're separated with all
these DTS in the DDS and then I just
construct this string cases which does a
string cases when the string cases and
attracts the extracts information out
but it all it does is is is get the name
see name here is is right there and the
Department is there and then I get the
email address out and and then that's it
and all I have to do is then slop that
slop that function that I created into
an API function and have some parameters
so have some parameters here and some of
them have default values and it will
just it you know defaults to a hundred
results so what I could do let's see is
it's a parameter max because I hoped up
to all the parameters in this API I can
say I can just want ten results yeah so
there you go so now I've got ten results
so so I hook up into this API as I all
of it all of the parameters that can
happen okay so last example report
generation so as I am out of time I want
to show you the the api's but basically
I can run this report i hook up to some
vba code and sure what i should be able
to do is run stock report this amazing
little thing that I created in VBA our
selection place is and I'll submit it
will tell me that my report is being
generated essentially and it will be
emailed to me so we'll wait a little bit
for that because you don't have to
generate the report have to get a
service cone or whatever probably take
like a minute maybe while waiting for
that let me show you the cloud API
dialog so the time API dialog
is another simple layer for for people
to be able to to get out a template of a
PR construction so let's say I have it
already auto completed for me because it
saves the api's but basically I've typed
in demo XR so it's just this adding API
and so it's a little bit small it gives
me the API parameters so there's an x
and a y I say I want the output to be
here I want X to be far four and Y to be
six and I'll insert and then it will
fill out that API for me right here
which is really really useful so so yeah
it's pretty it's pretty nice little
function that was added so stores the
API is as I showed you and it's it's
quick to use so people really really
unfamiliar and they can use it so there
are three user types essentially or we
have the excelled user the developer and
the system administrator basically the
Excel user doesn't know any Wolfram
language and they just want to be able
to use Excel the developer you know is
able to write code in the Wolfram
language and the system administrator
they have just one centralized server to
to to to to manage essentially so all of
these user types benefit from this
product which is great so about the
release of the product we are planning a
preview release we hope to have it done
today but part of it was my fault that
things got slow so hopefully by the end
of this month we will have a release for
you and you'll be able to download the
product and access it so so yeah when
can you get it in the month who can get
it it's going to be a download available
to everyone it is an EPC only product at
the moment but you can technically run
it on the public cloud and we can talk
about that at some point anyone who has
has interest I'm going to give you a
form that you can fill out we can we can
we can have email
and we can talk about that so website
documentation we're gonna have here's
the website very swanky talks about
these users to use the types workflow
comparing normal Excel to to the cloud
connector and how easy it is why so this
this is where we go through the user
types and it has a lot more information
about you know why these users benefit
the documentation is is still in
production I've almost finished it but
basically it gives you all the in from
all the user types are catered for here
and we have information on how each one
sets up their their infrastructure etc
etc so yeah summary yeah so what the
kind of features that we have is we can
call Excel functions with these Wolfram
api's we have support for any Wolfram
language expression you saw this matrix
expansion which I didn't make a big deal
of because I'm cool and everything but
it's really cool I think the the the
matrix expansion which you saw you can
reference local files again another
really cool thing you know these these
outputs automatically update and you
have a convenient I GUI for for these
api's so this is the bit of the mission
prompt so register your interest rule
through door am cloud connector I made
this I made this form just put in your
name and your email address and it will
send me an email and I will I will
remember you and when this product is
ready for release I will email you
personally maybe so
thank you very much for listening sorry
that I have run
you